He asks: when society collapses, will we see
a greater die out of intelligent people,
since they've been out of darwinian selection
for longer, and therefore have more mutations.
And also the fact that they live more in cities?
well, it's interesting.
I've always wondered, it's not so much the
high IQ types, it's the high
specialists.
So it's those individuals who have become
extremely specialized,
the K strategists.
They're the ones who are going to suffer in
the event of a large-scale
civilizational declension event.
So where the civilization just shifts into
a lower state of development,
or literally collapses at the core, it transitions
from say urbanization to agriculture,
just like that due to the mother of all economic
contractions-
And we end up like north korea.
If you read descriptions of the famine in
the 90s, it was people like teachers and doctors,
they just couldn't make any money, they worked
for the state but weren't being paid, and
they died.
And it was people that had broader set of
skills, such that they could let's say produce
food and sell it
where more likely to survive.
you're shifting the
selection pressure from specialists to generalists
essentially, and insofar as high IQ people
might be
somewhat more likely to be specialists, they
will die out to a greater extent.
So it will select for more intelligent R strategists,
I suppose.
It would do in theory.
So people (leaders) who can organize
production, who are highly generalized, and
who are
very very good at being able to quickly adapt.
People who are very good obligate generalists,
that is people very good at being able to
move around unstable niches, and they can
always get
the group to a position in the niche where
it's going to be able to profit.
And these
people might be a bit exploitative, and a
bit crude, and a bit psychopathic.
So it might be those people who end up flourishing
in
leadership roles in that civilizational context.
So yeah that's a very good
question, it'd be a good basis I think for
a science fiction book actually, if someone
was
inclined in a literary way to try and imagine
what the world would be like in say the star
trek date, 22 65.
Write a novel about 2265, the serious version
of idiocracy.